[Music]
good morning and welcome to trevor
phillips on sunday live from the
conservative party conference in
manchester
there are a few certainties in the
political journalists life
but one of them is that at the
conservative party conference the tory
faithful are looking to their leaders to
deliver on three promises
lower crime
lower immigration and lower taxes on
each front the prime minister is faced
with a crisis
most immediately this weekend how to
respond to the dreadful tragedy of sarah
everard's murder and the many more like
it at least 79 women have been killed by
men since her death in march
second even with military tanker drivers
delivering petrol to forecourt
there still aren't enough drivers and
the prospect of christmas dinner without
the trimmings is looming
and lurking behind all of this tax
the government didn't cause cobid but it
looks like they'll be asking us to pay
for it and at a time when everything
else from gas prices to grocery bills is
going up too well can we stave off chaos
we'll try to see in the next hour
here in manchester i'll be speaking to
the conservative party chairman oliver
dowden
winter's coming so we'll also be joined
by the king of the north
that's what his supporters call him andy
burnham
we'll ask former chief superintendent
palm sandu what the police have to do to
win back trust
and we'll put the same question to
former women and equalities minister
nikki morgan
cop chief executive steve merrells tells
us what they're doing to try and keep
food on the shelves this christmas
and we'll be asking the architect of
universal credit ian duncan smith why he
believes now is not the time to take
away 20 pounds a week from hard-pressed
families
but first
oliver dowden
good morning mr dowden good morning um
sarah everard's murder was called the
rapist by former colleagues he
had been seen exposing himself his car
was identified
is there going to be an independent
inquiry into how such a person
could come to be a metropolitan police
officer
yes well i agree with you it is deeply
deeply disturbing and i think uh all of
us feel it acutely
for two reasons one of which is
we can we've all walked in that sort of
area we've imagined that happening to
one of our our loved ones and our hearts
go out to sarah everard's
family but also the sort of things that
you've described the the kind of warning
signals that appear to have been
overlooked i do think it's important as
a first step that crested dick as the
commissioner properly investigates that
and i think we need to just let her get
on with the job of doing that first well
of course the question that's being
asked is
this happened on christopher dick's
watch the procedures that allowed him to
become a met police officer and the
culture
that as far as we can tell appear to
turn a blind eye
either developed
or continued
under her aegis is she really the right
person to do that
well you're absolutely right to
highlight all of those concerns and i'm
i'm very worried about them as well as
is the home secretary
the home secretary has made it clear and
i think the home secretary is clearly
right in this that
she should allow the met commissioner to
to do the job of trying to sort this out
and find out exactly how this happened
there are very serious questions to be
answered about the the kind of
oversights that you've described i think
the best approach is the one outlined by
the home secretary which is that we we
allow the commissioner to do that but
alongside that the government is taking
action so just today we're announcing 25
million pounds for our safer streets
fund which will help for example we want
cctv and other things to to help women
feel safer i want to come to that um but
let's assume that chris dick does her
exercise would you still rule out the
idea of an independent inquiry into
these vetting procedures because this is
clearly not just a problem for the met
this is a problem for
every constabulary
well i think it's it's important that
this work is done first of all by the
the commissioner of course we don't rule
anything out there but i think it's it's
important for us to understand exactly
what happened and if there are further
questions uh arising from that then it
may be that we need to look at it
further but i think the first step is
really to get to the bottom it that's
what cresta dick has been tasked with
what that's what she said she is getting
on with with doing i think it's
important that we allow her to do that
if it is the case that subsequently we
need to look at it then of course we we
don't rule that out this um
this issue
this tragedy has thrown up some
issues
which are wider even than the police now
in your
job as chair of the conservative party
you're responsible for party discipline
um philip allert who is the conservative
uh crime commissioner for north
yorkshire
told women this week that they needed to
be more streetwise now he's apologized
for that
but shouldn't you have been on the phone
telling him
he had to go the minute you heard that
well the prime minister and i were
outraged by what he said it was
completely unacceptable uh i've been
very clear in condemning it i know the
prime minister shares that view uh he
did immediately apologize and i think
that that's appropriate for him to do so
can women in north yorkshire be uh at
least clear that uh when you next offer
a candidate for this role to the
electorate it uh the name won't be
philip allert well it was i'm not going
to preempt the the selection because
you're in charge of candidates uh well
we go through a proper transparent
process with that but i uh be in no
doubt at all that the prime minister and
i
profoundly disagreed with what he said
it was a stupid thing to have said and
he has rightly apologized for it
if uh but of course if you lived in
north orchard and you had a vote
you wouldn't be casting it for this
gentleman would you well let's wait for
the the selection process for the for
the new pcc okay let's pass on from that
ringing vote of confidence in mr alex
too back to the this central issue um
there's a suggestion that somehow the
wayne cousins is a sort of single bad
apple
um
that can't be true can it for example uh
other officers exchanged messages with
him
which clearly
were part of this pattern of appalling
behavior
um
do you think that those people should be
kicked out of the police
well of course
anyone who has
breached police conduct rules should
should face appropriate disciplinary
action i do think though it's important
and i'm sure your viewers appreciate and
i appreciate the vast majority of police
officers do an incredible amount of hard
work keeping us safe every single day i
saw that just
yesterday when i visited gold command
for our conference 1 500 police officers
working day and night to make sure that
everyone's safe most police officers are
deeply noble and committed to keeping
the public safe it is important though
that of course we address situations
where they rise the kind of appalling
conduct of of this person and i think
that's that's why the the met
commissioner is rightly investigating it
properly you've mentioned the uh 25
million pounds at home secretaries
committed to projects that are going to
make the streets safer
the examples that have been given are
locked gates to alleyways
better street liking lighting cctv
can you explain to me how any of that
would have prevented the death of sarah
everard
well those are wider measures to to make
sure that uh women feel safe and people
in general feel safe and those those
measures will help people feel safer
clearly
there are questions
none of that would have interfered and
of course what that man did
you're absolutely right
to highlight what i think is an
underlying point about the
the fear that that i have and and others
have that there will be a loss of trust
uh particularly amongst uh younger women
with the uh with the police uh and
crested it because has made it clear
that
she's got a big job of work to
restore that trust and that that that
goes alongside though the kind of action
in the women and girls strategy and the
safer street strategy which is about um
making sure that people feel safer
generally uh there's no silver bullet to
restoring that the the trust that that
people feel with the the police but i
know that the
the commissioner takes it exceptionally
seriously about how we can rebuild that
trust well well here's one way you could
address this um another
former
um
female police chief sue fish who ran
nottinghamshire police
has said
recently
that what should be happening is that we
should be treating
the issue of violence against women and
girls
as seriously
as we treat counter-terrorism now we're
sitting a few hundred meters away from
where the manchester arena bombing took
place 22 people lost their lives
the government party's response to that
focused on reducing the threat through
the prevent programme
which
uh disrupts
anticipates uh diverts people
do we need to prevent program for male
violence against women and girls
well actually we're taking a a range of
measures to to address violence against
women girls whether that's in relation
to our recent sentencing bill which is
massively toughened up sentencing
whether it's in relation to in my former
brief uh ensuring that uh women and
girls are safe online with massive fines
for social media companies that fail to
deal with this tide of vile misogyny
that we see on on social media so the
government is actually working across
the progress
yes although that that said um vicky
atkins the excellent minister in the
home office is essentially coordinating
all of that on behalf of the home
secretary ensuring that we have a joined
up approach to to doing so and has been
specifically tasked by the prime
minister to do that and that that's the
approach we're taking it it goes across
a range of different government
activities all right let's um talk about
uh the other big issue of this weekend
that's economy cost of living
um
you and your fellow ministers are
telling us there's no shortage of fuel
but the petrol retailers say that the
cues on the four courts are persisting
in some parts of the country
and if anything they're getting worse
it really isn't stabilizing is it well i
think it it depends where you are in the
country so for example around here in
manchester uh i was out and about
yesterday there's the i didn't see any
problems with uh petrol stations you can
get fuel pretty easily here there is
clearly a problem still in uh london and
the south east and people feel deeply
frustrated and i i share their um their
anger and frustration not not being able
to get access to petrol that's why the
government is working tirelessly to to
resolve that situation and just a
further step we're taking is that from
tomorrow those 200 military personnel
will be
deployed to help drive tankers to ensure
that that we overcome this issue which
as as your your viewers know and i know
you appreciate it's not that there is a
lack of yeah petrol is about getting the
petrol to the the the petrol stations
but look this is not just about about
petrol and um
if i can give you an example forgive me
if i'm a little grumpy with you this
morning um
we couldn't get
uh
any pastries from our favorite coffee
shop here in manchester this morning and
worse still
they told us they didn't have paper for
the receipts so i'm not going to get my
expenses from sky news we're facing a
series of shortages
and there doesn't seem to be any
consciousness in government
about what is really going on in on the
ground we're getting a lot of
reassurance but we're actually not
getting our buns
well i i very much hope you you got your
pastries in the end i think i've got
some spare pastries in my room i can
bring them to you afterwards if you're
still feeling peckish but on the the
more serious underlying point uh about
uh supply chains there are challenges uh
with supply chains we're not unique in
the uk in this for example if you look
uh across poland the u.s other countries
there are there are shortages of drivers
that's to do with a range of factors not
least the fact that testing wasn't
happening during covert you've got an
aging population of drivers but we are
taking steps to address that whether
that is extending the amount of time
before you have to renew your license
whether that is uh beefing up capacity
to do tests we we are we are dealing
with those issues but use the board but
you can't promise me that there's going
to be turkey there's going to be turkey
on the table at christmas can you we are
may we will make sure that people have
their their turkeys for christmas and i
know that the the environment secretary
george justice this is absolutely top of
his his list
all right um
you are now in charge of the electorate
electoral machine for the conservatives
um
has the prime minister told you to get
ready for an election in 2023
well the prime minister has told me to
make sure that the conservative party
machine is is ready to go for an
election when whenever it comes but also
to make sure that i as the conservative
party chairman i'm a strong voice for
the conservative party and the
conservative values including in in the
media in in this discussion that we're
we're having now so we could be asked to
vote again in 2023 no that right now we
are absolutely focused on getting on
with the job of making sure that we
deliver for the british people i can
assure you that prime minister
chancellor home secretary they're not
speculating about elections day in day
out sleeves are rolled up they're
focused on on delivering well but you
know i'm going to ask you you're not
going to rule out a 2023 election i it's
not my job to call an election uh but we
we know full well that the usual
electoral cycle would take you through
to 2024 but that's that's entirely up to
the prime minister
one last thing when you get there what
are you going to be telling us um
there is a question at the moment about
whether conservatives are truly
conservatives biggest tax risers biggest
tax burden i beg your pardon since the
war no sign of any cuts in taxes um
can you rule out and i know you'll say
this as a chancellor but let me put it
this way would you oliver daldon
be uh
opposed to any further tax writers
before the next election well the
conservative party has always been the
party of low taxes and indeed we've cut
taxes
i'll come to that in a second but if you
look at your our record in office since
2010 we massively increased the personal
allowance delivering a huge tax cut to
millions of of working families of
course we had to deal with this covert
crisis and we were we were faced with a
choice uh did we get the resources into
the nhs so it recovers from covert i
think it was the right thing to do and
did we pay for that property did we
burden our children and grandchildren
with more borrowing or do we take the
difficult decision up front and i think
that is entirely consistent with a
conservative principle of sound public
money living within your means making
sure we don't pass on burdens to our
children and grandchildren but as soon
as we can
make sure that we keep the tax burden
know and reduce it of course we will do
so oliver darden thank you very much
indeed thank you
now it seems unlikely that the city's
mayor can expect a comradely greeting
from the conservative party conference
but some think that he's the leader of
the opposition's biggest threat so who
knows
i'm joined by labour's andy burdham
who's just down the road in salford
good morning mr mayor now you aren't
responsible for the metropolitan police
but but you pointed out yesterday uh
that you took action to change
the leadership in manchester uh when you
thought they weren't doing their job
harriet hartmann says that cressida dick
has to go because she can't inspire
trust kia stammer says she should stay
is harriet right or care
so
it's very difficult for me to comment on
that trevor because as you pointed out i
do have the formal responsibility
of uh assessing the performance of a
chief constable and where necessary uh
making a change which i did uh late last
year so you know if i were to pass
comment on this situation obviously it
has some wider resonance uh than me just
being you know giving an off-the-cuff
view and because i don't have you know
the inside information
to be honest i'm not going to to pass a
sort of knee-jerk uh a knee-jerk view
the only thing i would say is obviously
this is the most senior policing
position in the land we have a woman in
that in that role i i would say that
should give some confidence that from
here
a convincing strategy can emerge from
the met but more broadly to tackle
violence against women and girls
well you say that
but a former chief constable sue fish
who ran nottinghamshire i was just
talking to
the conservative party chairman about uh
what she said
one of the other things that she said in
an interview yesterday was that
when she tried to draw attention to some
of these issues choose denigrated
isolated and marginalized by many senior
people including and she names her
crested dick now
of course you can't make a a judgment
but do you think
that given what is now being said and
the issue of confidence do you think it
is reasonable
for londoners to feel that
crested dick is the right person to
solve the problem that have occurred on
her watch given your experience in
manchester
oh it's certainly reasonable for the
question to be asked and for the debate
to be had
of course that's the case uh trevor but
you know it wouldn't be right for the
mayor of greater manchester
to be telling the mayor of london uh or
indeed londoners who should run the
metropolitan police i i will if you
don't mind leave that question to them
what i would say is some of the
statements that came out from the met
over the weekend felt like they were
going down the wrong track you know
women should wave down a bus any answer
to this uh issue that begins with the
words women should or women must is in
my view the wrong answer this is an
issue that starts with men
and boys and that is where attention
should go
and i would say all of us actually need
to start building from that from that
that starting point i am going to lead
personally
a high-profile public education campaign
in greater manchester aimed at men and
boys which will talk about how our
behavior can make women feel uh when
perhaps they're out late at night on
public transport or walking in a dark
street i think we need to take this much
more seriously i i speak to my teenage
daughters my youngest daughter the other
day says you know wolf whistling is just
kind of routine and but it has an impact
and and how can that be right you know
40 year old men wolf whistling 16 year
old girls that kind of thing
people should be embarrassed uh to to do
that that kind of thing has to be called
out and actually trevor other men have
to call it out against friends who do it
and this is the kind of conversation i
think we now need to have about this
issue
rather than lurching to knee-jerk
solutions that might you know please a
headline in a newspaper but not actually
provide a solution
indeed and you you've pointed out this
is not just a london or a met problem
what happened here in manchester
after the manchester arena bombing
was a real
renewed focus on counter-terrorism
some people have been saying that
actually we need that level of focus on
the question of violence against women
and girls would you support the proposal
that i think has been come forward today
that there should be a prevent program
diversion interception
identification of likely offenders
there should be a prevent program that
focuses on violence against women and
girls that is as resourced and as
uh significant as a one that we've used
against islam islamist terrorism
so i probably wouldn't call it that in
terms of a prevent program or you know
make the com direct correlation with
terrorism but if you're saying there's a
need for a national program
where this is taken much more seriously
and all police forces in england and
wales are required
to make this a a high priority which it
would seem the government is currently
resisting then yes i would absolutely
say say yes uh to that because i do
think this needs uh sustained effort on
every single level
at the front door of the police station
in terms of how police treat victims the
training for police officers but that
broader public engine education campaign
i was talking about a moment ago so
absolutely to a yes to a national
resource program that kind of takes this
whole issue into a completely different
space with regard to the focus that it
gets and for me that is what was coming
out after the appalling murder of sarah
everard that was the call coming from
women and girls right across the country
and it has to be heard trevor i think
there's a danger of words not deeds here
and i think we need the opposite we need
to see action uh against uh violence
against women and girls in the aftermath
of sarah's murder i brought forward the
conversation on the strategy
to tackle this issue here in greater
manchester and we've just passed our
strategy uh in just the last week so we
are taking it seriously but i would only
support a national program i'd like uh
to to give further i'd like to i'd like
to get on
i'd like to get on to leveling up very
quickly but very briefly um would you
support
an independent inquiry into the vetting
procedures which
applies to all uh constabularies because
we've now learnt that this man cousins
could even now
have got through the vetting procedures
that gave him a uniform and a warrant
card
yes in a word i i would i think that
does need to be to be looked at and i
also think there needs to be an inquiry
into the the broader culture uh within
police forces and we're certainly doing
that here in greater manchester because
we've acknowledged the culture in our
own police force hasn't been right but
perhaps some of those subcultures within
within police forces those closed uh
those closed whatsapp
group so i think all of this is where we
need to go perhaps as part of that that
national drive that you were pointing to
i think what is indisputable is that
this issue needs to to move up uh
several several rungs up the ladder in
terms of the prioritization and you know
that that that much is is unarguable i
would say trevor
okay
you and the um other big city mayors met
the prime minister this week
you now have a new secretary of state
for leveling up in the shape of michael
go if you'd had your choice um
would it have been michael gove
you know i think it probably would
uh given given
the choice of ministers around
because
while i don't always agree with him
michael does bring
real energy to what he does intellect
and i would expect that leveling up
won't remain
undefined for much longer now michael is
in charge of debris so i actually think
it was good news
for for levelling up we we haven't met
the prime minister actually we we met
michael last week and had a very good
conversation with him and as the
conservatives come to manchester for
their conference i'm not going to rerun
the arguments of 2020. we're still sure
if we're honest about about that the
pandemic has hit us really hard but i
don't think it would get the people here
anywhere so what i'm saying to michael
gove and the prime minister as they
arrive here in manchester is here is a
big positive offer from us let us help
you define leveling up and let us help
you deliver leveling up and in our case
that means a london-style public
transport system for greater monster
crucially with london level fares where
it's one pound 55
to catch a bus uh compared to the four
pounds or more that people have to pay
here
can i just put this to you uh you've
made this transport plan the the center
piece of your uh proposals for leveling
up um can't tell you what i think
they're saying in well i know because
they said it to me in rochdale and
oldham and bolton this is all very well
but this is just andy's plan
uh to allow us
to have to to travel into manchester
central but actually none of this is
going to help uh the really depressed
parts of the greater manchester who are
the rochdales
and the oldhams and to some extent
boltons you can name them yourselves but
actually this is really a city center
mayor
mayor at work rather than a mayor for
the whole of manchester
no
that isn't the case i can understand why
people say that but but trevor this
system that i'm talking about would
would be for all 2.8 million residents
of greater manchester and it would
better to connect them to jobs and
opportunities in their own boroughs but
also further afield and you know this
place i'm talking to now is salford it's
very hard to get from rochdale or oldham
uh to media city so it would help
connect people to jobs in any part of
greater manchester but the critical
thing is this actually we're already
beginning to see how a strong city
centre lifts the towns outside of it
stockport has a mayoral development
corporation where there are plans for
3500 homes and i would like to bring one
to middleton uh in the borough of of
rochdale just between uh you know on the
fringes of of manchester we think this
plan will help lift the proud
mill towns of of greater manchester
particularly those across the north and
so it's about town and city rising
together and we think we've got evidence
to show that
andy burnham thank you very much indeed
you're welcome now the murder of sarah
everard by an off-duty constable who was
known to some colleagues as the rapist
has raised serious questions for the
metropolitan police
the forces admitted making mistakes in
the vetting process that led to the
recruitment of wayne cousins who this
week received a whole life sentence i'm
joined now by the former superintendent
in the metropolitan police palm sandu
palm sandy thank you very much for
joining us
the commissioner of the metropolitan
police essentially said she used the
word
abaddon that uh wayne cousins was an
exceptional
uh case a bad apple as it were a one-off
and that everybody else would be
appalled by his behavior
do you agree that he's just a one-off
good morning trevor first of all what i
would like to say is that the majority
of police officers are good caring
officers who are there for the right
reasons
wayne cousins was a monster in uniform
but unfortunately there is a culture
where he was allowed to flourish and the
whatsapp group that he was a part of and
other people are
is just one sign of that and i've heard
other comments about right across the
country about this sort of culture
existing i have experienced it and i
feel that it is time for all police
officers and all members of the public
to stand up and say enough is enough
you uh just said whatsapp groups are are
you aware that these kinds of whatsapp
groups
still exist amongst police officers
i am aware because i even spoke to one
of my colleagues yesterday and when
officers whether they're male or female
some of them are calling it out
and when they do call it out they are
then denied job opportunities contracts
are not extended and they are the ones
who get vilified
in my view what we should be doing and
i've talked about this before is there
should be a support bubble around
individuals who are strong enough and
brave enough to fight this
but it should go one step further
we should be actively encouraging people
to come forward and say
this is not right this is what's
happening and let's take action together
but moving on from that it's not just
about police this is a societal issue
and when we talk about
deaths there are more deaths through
domestic violence than there is through
counterterrorism or knife crime yet we
have task force forces we have units
that deal with those particular crimes
how come we don't have anything like
that for domestic violence how come we
don't have the same sort of money being
spent on it
i'd like to come back to the the wider
set of issues in a moment but just
sticking with the police for the moment
is it your belief
that there could be
other wayne cousins
types of people currently wearing the
uniform carrying a warrant card
and that the current vetting procedures
uh and management procedures of the met
and other police forces simply won't be
picking them up
i have real serious concerns about the
vetting procedures this man not only got
through the vetting after indecency
offences in 2015 in 2018 he was taken in
the met
he was then given a gun to carry on the
streets of london so that was another
form of vetting
i believe there are in other individuals
who have got questionable backgrounds
who should be being looked at
not just in the met right up and down
the country and i think we have missed
that and instead of looking backwards we
should be looking forward and making
sure that those individuals are targeted
now
do you think that that means that
to understand
how to target them that there should be
an
independent inquiry
into the vetting procedures
there should be an independent inquiry
but in addition to that everybody who
works in policing now should be
re-vetted those people who have got
through the vetting procedure 20 years
ago 30 years ago all of them
every single person needs to be reviewed
and if anything comes up in their past
and it doesn't have to be a conviction
it just needs to be come to notice
because this man did come to notice so
every person should be re-vetted and
re-assessed as to whether or not they
are safe to be working with members of
the community and members of the public
to be clear every every police officer
should go through the vetting procedure
once more
uh is that
as a one-off or do you think that's
something that should be done
periodically every few years
it needs to be done now as an urgent
measure to reassure the public and
rebuild the trust and confidence that
policing has lost but it needs to be
done on a regular basis so that we don't
have anybody who can even come close to
the actions of wayne cousins we need to
make sure that we restore that trust and
confidence and in my view you know i've
heard the your previous guests who have
spoken about
the next steps and the commissioner has
reassured them that she's going to take
action
well i haven't actually seen the
commissioner standing in front of the
camera saying i'm sorry and now i want
to listen to you i've heard her say
sorry but i haven't heard her say i now
want your views i want to set up a focus
group an urgent task group i've heard
the um
houses of parliament were also guarded
by wayne cousins and there's going to be
an urgent review and inquiry into that
and there's going to be a conversation
with the commissioner but what about
normal people what about the normal
people who are walking around the
streets of london who's talking to them
who's listening to them
and i accept that the contract the
commissioners contract has been extended
by two years well let's make it a
positive two years
why you know from now
the commissioner has got two years to
turn this around she needs to be taking
immediate action and
gone
you think she's the wrong you think
she's the wrong person to do this job
don't you
i it doesn't matter what i think the
decisions have been made so we have to
live with that but now it's about making
that positive difference going forward
and over the weekend scottish police
have decided that if a loan officer
stops a female they're going to put
their radios on loudspeakers so they can
speak to the control room how come we're
not we're not hearing that from the met
all we've heard is flag down a bus
well that's okay that's fine for the
first day for the first 24 hours but
we're not in the first 24 hours now
because the commissioner and the top
team have had time to think about what's
the next steps
okay can i return to the wider point
that i think you wanted to make which is
about the culture and
this is not just a question i think
applies to the police but pretty much to
every workplace but you can tell us uh
something about this
how is it that you think
that wayne cousins with all the points
that you've made about him being
identified
people knowing he'd exposed himself and
all that
how is it that nobody said anything
trevor i wish i knew the answer to that
question and i would be surprised if no
one did say anything i think that in the
coming days and weeks we may find that
individuals did raise issues but they
were just not acted on because there
isn't that
support there isn't that strength of
feeling to take matters further and in a
lot of cases the canteen culture is such
that oh she couldn't take a joke it was
just banter it meant nothing and i i
wouldn't be surprised if in the next few
weeks we find that people did raise
these issues
palm sandu thank you very much indeed
for your time
thank you
now it emerged this morning that one of
the jobs given to sarah everard's killer
was to guard mps at westminster
i'm joined now by the former women's and
equalities minister baroness morgan
um nicki morgan
we learned this morning that this man
wayne cousins
was assigned to the house of commons to
guard
mps
of which you would have been one
um
what's your reaction to discovering that
well good morning trevor um well my
reaction to to that actually is that um
of course it's a it's a development in
the story but actually this is not about
parliament this is not about um the
guarding of uh of parliament there's
always an issue about vetting i know
you've been talking to other guests
about that but i really hope we don't
make this about parliament um because
actually this is about the safety of
women and girls across the country many
of whom don't work in a very protective
place like parliament and westminster
and many of whom do
exactly what sarah everard does and they
did and they they do it every day which
is to walk somewhere home decide perhaps
not to get a bus to go for a run
um and if they were stopped by a police
officer perhaps until last week they
would have done what they were asked to
do um now of course that relationship of
trust between the police and i think
many women and girls in this country is
teetering on a knife edge and there's a
a lot of work for the police uh to do
and i think we need to concentrate on
that rather than this development about
parliament and it may well turn out he's
guarded other places too we just don't
know but actually it's about the safety
of women and girls like sarah everard
palm sanders just suggested that every
police officer
uh should be re-vetted
would you agree with that
well i would agree with that um and i
think as your other some of your other
guests have said already this is um a
much broader cultural issue i mean it's
kind of inevitable that we are this
morning talking about whether it's
vetting um or we're talking about how
exactly uh wayne cousins got to the
position that he was in was able to move
forces and of course that has got to be
looked at but there's also a broader
cultural issue i think what palm sound
is just saying it's not it's in it's in
all workplaces actually it's in
all organizations and it's on our
streets as well whereby it is just
appalling and unacceptable that women
and girls do not feel safe when they are
walking around often in broad daylight
that's a cultural issue and that's a
cultural issue that the police have
absolutely got to get to grips with and
frankly that's the test for cressida
dick you know
i'd like to hear from her a plan about
how she is going to tackle
changing the culture in the met and
actually from all the other potential
chief constables as well now at that
point that's the test for whether she
keeps the job or not
let's address this this wider cultural
issue one aspect of this is who should
be responsible for
fixing the problem as it were well we've
heard um the reaction for example to the
met advice that uh women should wave
down a bus i don't think we need to
detain ourselves on that but more
importantly i suppose i talked a little
earlier on to the party chairman about
the remarks of the north yorkshire
police and crime commissioner who said
that women need to be streetwise about
when they can be arrested and when they
can't be arrested
um
that oliver dowden said he and the prime
minister were outraged but i don't think
they were outraged enough to say this
person should be should not be a member
of the conservative party what do you
think
well i mean i have to say i think they
were incredibly stupid remarks um and
they were delivered by somebody who
clearly has never been in a situation
where they have uh walked down a street
and heard footsteps behind them and
wondered uh you know what's going to
happen in the next couple of minutes
uh got the keys out their bags in order
to be able to uh to defend themselves if
they if they have to um and frankly for
a police and crime commissioner to uh
basically hint that actually um women
need to be more uh aware um about uh
more skeptical actually if a police
officer uh stops them um i think is
frankly uh extraordinary
um i mean i have to i'm not in favor i
mean i hope that um that philip allen
has been uh contacted by whether it's
the party chairman whether it's the home
secretary whether it's the prime
minister and asked to explain himself um
and you know again at the end of the day
if somebody senior has said something or
not done something i would rather they
actually admitted a mayor called i've
got this wrong here's my plan for doing
it
rather than you know throwing people out
of the party or or getting them to
resign imminently so i think we better
hear from mr allen what his plan is and
if i were a woman in his police and a
crime krishna area then i would want to
hear from him what his plan is actually
make women feel safer when they're going
about their lives
but i suppose what i'm really
trying to get at here is that this is an
example of what i think you would say
you would describe as part of the
cultural problem that actually
the the big issue andy burnham talked
about this uh
a moment ago the big issue here is
not that women need to fix this but
there needs to be something
about the way that men behave now one of
the things we've heard about in this
week is the locker room
culture
that female police officers describe
one of the reasons that you left the
house of commons is that uh you said
that um
you got lots of abuse and we know that
women mps are more likely to get abuse
and be undermined than male mps do you
think we can do anything about this kind
of culture
the answer is i i do think we can do
something about it and i know that there
is a huge determination amongst
ministers amongst the speaker of the
house of commons for example to tackle
um online abuse of members of parliament
but also actually the the new elections
bill proposes um
makes proposals about the intimidation
of candidates for example but you're
absolutely right trevor this is a wider
broader problem that has gone un
um
untested for or unchallenged for far too
long and of course as well as being
minister for women equalities a few
years ago i was also education secretary
and i heard what andy burnham said and i
think he uh is correct to say that
actually this is um also a challenge for
men to to call out when they hear
unacceptable language or so-called
banter being used but actually it starts
right the way at schools and um the pshe
curriculum
is so important in what it teaches
both boys and girls about respect for
themselves but about issues about uh
consent about the language that we use
um you know when i was education
secretary i talked a lot about character
that's also about thinking about the
impact that you're having on people
around you wanting to do the right thing
even when somebody is not looking all of
that and then of course oliver dowden
also rightly highlighted um
and again as a former culture secretary
the impact that the online harms bill
will need to have about making sure
because sadly a lot of abuse i suffered
and others suffer i think is absolutely
fueled by the misogyny that is allowed
to go rampant on our social media
platforms
actually that bill will be very
important again in beginning to change
the culture of those platforms make
those tech companies accountable for
what's on there getting that content off
and saying being transparent about how
they do that and ofcom policing that to
make sure they are doing what they say
they're going to to protect the users of
those platforms
indeed just very briefly of course
at the center of this is still the issue
of
uh the way that
women are spoken about and regard and so
on and this is a non-partisan point when
harriet harman was in government
there were things said about her
you know obsessed by women's issues and
so on and we we see to some extent um
the
treatment of uh liz truss and priti
patel
do you think that actually
there is a problem in
politics that
prominent women are not spoken about or
regarded in the same way as prominent
men
i don't think it's universal but i think
a lot of the coverage
of women in politics still focuses far
too much on obviously um what we are uh
how we are presenting rather than what
we are actually saying i mean i think we
remember that picture do you remember of
theresa may nicola sturgeon when they
first met and that you know that picture
of them sitting there and um i think was
more commentary about their knees being
on show than what they actually said in
their meeting and of course i remember
walking down downing street and
somewhere there's a very unattractive
picture of me
and uh because uh i was walking down
without my rod and the photographer
shouted out girls girls and i was like
no girls we are secretaries of state and
i think absolutely the language that
people use as i say about all of us um
uh people in public life generally uh
obviously uh matters and again we all
have to think about that at all times it
is much better than i think it it was uh
but there's always room for not just in
westminster in all organizations and of
course the spotlight is very firmly on
our police forces at the moment
nikki morgan thank you very much indeed
thank you
now christmas is coming
but don't assume the goose is getting
fat there's a warning that the supply
crisis currently showed causing
shortages at petrol stations around the
country could also lead to empty shells
in the shops this christmas
steve murrells is the boss of the co-op
which has more stores than any other
supermarket in the country except tesco
and sainsbury's um
steve morales um
there's a co-op
at the
corner
of my street it's nearest grocer um
can you promise that i'll be able to
walk to the corner and get sausages for
my stuffing uh on christmas day
good morning trevor thanks for inviting
me on yes i can assure you that you will
get your stuffing at christmas time um
to coin a phrase um we're working very
hard to get all the christmas favorites
for our customers the members
and um and you should be reassured about
that what i can say however is is that
this isn't a co-op problem uh it's not
even a national problem it's a global
issue
one that isn't going to be fixed quickly
and will need real structural change and
as goods move across the world they've
become quite dislocated um from its end
use so
whilst the government's recent actions
around visas and extending time periods
is going to help there is no doubt
this will take some while to fix and
requires a real
change in mindset on how we move goods
around the globe
i'll come to that in a second but you
you said back in august that the
shortages then were the worst that you
had seen in your
time in in retail um
is that still the case today
yes we're still um seeing daily that the
challenges of this perfect storm a storm
that's affecting all retailers
all suppliers
and that is still with us here today
things are improving
not as fast as we would all like
but yes they continue to exist and
as i say
we're all working extremely hard to fix
the issue which is 90 000 hgv drivers
too short from what we all require
um
money is going to help but it's not the
answer here it requires a complete
rethink
and trevor as you know we've just
recently come out with one of the
largest post pandemic surveys around
young people and their life aspirations
who i think can be part of the solution
around the issues that we're facing
today but worryingly they've told us
that they
sorry you're going to say something i
want to come to that i want to come to
the the longer term issues but um
you you
mentioned the 90 000
drivers that uh we need now the
government has said in effect this week
several ministers has made the same
point that the shortage of hgv drivers
is down to you and your fellow industry
bosses because instead of training our
young people what you did was mainline
on immigrant labor which was cheaper and
eat more easily available in essence
this
crisis is your fault
well i refute that completely um our
role as retailers is to provide um
the best value for money that we can for
those people that come and shop with us
whilst um making sure that those that
serve us are well rewarded for their
efforts
this has been an issue
that goes beyond retailing as far as the
demise and the number of drivers across
the uk
but again i i think that we have a
number of solutions in our grasp young
people will hopefully be one of those
well you're going to be here at the
conservative party conference this week
and i think you're making
the case uh for
uh greater skills training and so on um
what what are you going to be telling
the prime minister that he needs to do
well i think in in the same way i'm
saying the supply chain needs a
structural change um
we're going to need if leveling up is
going to be successful um a real
structural approach to leveling up uh if
we want it to be better and fairer and
as i
referred to at the beginning
this recent survey is showing us that
the younger generation
can play a significant part in in that
agenda but they are um disengaged and we
need to listen to their concerns and
their life aspirations
because they're telling us that they
have no hope
so what i'll be talking about is how
businesses like the co-op with
government and local leaders do need to
come together
to work on
solutions and pathways for young people
to achieve
their full potential and it shouldn't
matter where you come from trevor or
what color you are or what um gender or
religion you have i i believe that that
all
young
adults and students
need to have an equal chance in getting
on and and i think that will be
certainly a strong message that i'll be
giving
steve morales thank you very much
thank you
now two things are due to happen on
wednesday here in manchester the prime
minister boris johnson will make his
keynote speech to the conservative party
conference
on the same day the 20 pound a week
boost to universal credit introduced to
help people through the pandemic
officially comes to an end
i'm joined now by the former
conservative party leader and the
architect of universal credit ian duncan
smith perhaps even more relevant um
ian douglas smith is a former heavy
goods truck driver um in duncan smith
they need 90 000. um
i think you could be back on the road uh
this week and actually you could be
earning even more than you do as a
member of parliament
yeah sadly i let the i didn't renew the
license about 15 years or so ago but i
am now looking into whether it was
feasible to either get my license back
or get a test yes certainly i um i would
be game to get back in the cab as it
were um but the one thing i do know
[Music]
that's right the one point i was going
to make was one thing i do know about
this crisis
is that it isn't just sitting here
because we left the european union in
fact it's uh the the demand for drivers
and requirements drivers was growing as
far back as uh 2013 2014
and i had uh when i was secretary of
state working with a big rouse with the
hauliers uh i gathered them in with the
transport secretary and said why didn't
they train british drivers and they said
oh they just don't want to do it so we
bought a hundred courses got the price
down
filled all of them with people who were
unemployed and ended up getting them all
to pass and i went back to them and said
why didn't you do that
and they just shrugged their shoulders
said oh no it's all too difficult and in
fact the reason is because they didn't
want to have to commit financially to
train drivers they just got them in from
eastern europe but that market was
already freezing up and even now in
europe there's four hundred thousand a
shortage of drivers because of covid and
no testing which we same applies here so
always have got to get on with it and
finance the training
well look i wasn't going to go there but
since you've raised brexit um let's talk
let's talk about turkeys
the
turkey producers cannot get the labor
to process and pack turkeys we can't get
turkey pluckers and that is because of
brexit
are you embarrassed that in order to
have turkeys on the table at christmas
now because of brexit we've got to
import them from france and poland
no again this is all about planning i'm
afraid and kobe too because planning
first of all because
there are these uh short labor schemes
that exist for people that do seasonal
work
and so there are there are plenty of
opportunities for people to come in
to do this sort of work as much as
picking if they require to do it
that's the first particular short term
point the second point of course is
kovid meant that
we had about three million uh people who
were european union citizens who
registered here uh to allow them to stay
and to work kovid hit many of them went
back home many have discovered actually
they want to stay but the other bit i
have to tell you is i met a very
interesting man who produced potatoes
but it's very important this because he
cornered the market in the uk on frozen
potato products and all the supermarkets
and i asked him how he managed to do
that and he laughed he said the uk is a
cheap labor country you've never
invested in technology you don't invest
in people and it's going to hurt you
eventually well whether or not you leave
the european union you have businesses
that are not foresighted like we are and
therefore we beat them in the market
because we invested in technology that's
the story i'm afraid of uk business at
the moment
change
all right let's talk about universal
credit which was your creation
how did it feel to see it undermined by
the 20 pound cut this week
well actually was undermined under
george osborne when he took about 5
billion out of universal traded
originally when where we went it
meant it to be
some of that money's gone back in since
but it did require more investment and i
was pleased when these the chancellor
put
extra money in because it ensures that
people not just are supported well as
unemployed but i helped up the ladder
very quickly because of the taper it's
not an unemployment benefit it's an
employment and unemployment benefit and
it works when you invest in it because
dynamically the more people that move
off into work the lower the cost so i
would like to see them so you're okay
with me
no no i want to keep the money i think
it's the right thing to keep this
investment in universal credit it's been
a huge success of all the things that
have gone wrong in uh the pandemic
universal credit's the one thing that's
quietly got on and helps support people
without having to queue up at job
centres so it's worth investing in it
also gets people into work quicker so
that's worth investing in and finally
and the point i just made is importantly
that that money that cost will fall as
people go back into work so it's
important that we do this and even if
the government's determined to do this i
would urge them to think about this over
the period of the winter not do it now
and think about it again in february
march as they approach the budget when
they know what the cost of living is
when they know what inflation is and
they know what the difficulties are in
the marketplace far better to wait and
see where we are as we know things are
are moving in the wrong direction in
those terms and those will affect the
poorest in society the most so we need
to make sure we keep the support
measures in for them
so you're going to keep fighting through
on this through the winter
well you know the trouble is if you get
a vote i tried to amend a bill the other
day to get this
changed i suspect that bill will come
back from the lords amended i just keep
saying to my colleagues you know we
invest in the poorest and ensure that
they have a root out of poverty through
work
and universal credit was designed to do
that and it's been doing it brilliantly
so
the old rule
you uh you invest in success and
withdrawal from failure this is a
success use this don't invent our scheme
do
this you are a london member of
parliament
are the prime minister and the home
secretary right to stand by the
commissioner of the metropolitan police
i have resisted calls uh for her
resignation simply on the basis in the
past that i feel that these things don't
always change things in the short term
and when i saw the secretary of state uh
give her the second term a much much
limited one by the way then i assume
that was because they were looking for
somebody uh to replace her
i do think that the handling of certain
events in london has not been brilliant
anything from some of the protests the
prolonged protests now
of the extinction rebellion crowd that
have cost huge uh amounts of money and
worse in many senses as an outer borough
mb
stripped out the police forces from the
outer boroughs that's putting us in some
jeopardy uh during the course of this
but there's lots going on and i think
the um
the issues around uh um
the the recent murders the female
murders and uh the terrible problems
that have existed from that i think
there are issues here
about leadership and focus and i think
the met has got to sort of have somebody
in charge now that understands the
dynamic of what they do how it works
best and that people can rely on them to
be both
forceful where necessary but also
helpful and can be trusted and i think
that's the bit that's got to be resolved
and it may require that she
steps down and that somebody else is
able to take over because i think it is
time now for a new broom as it were
you've been um sold have you worn the
uniform you've held responsibility
it's a heavy responsibility to be a
police officer but this man
went through the vetting procedures and
got his uniform and warrant card
do you think
that actually the procedures are
right for
revision and that there should be an
independent inquiry
into the vetting procedures to become a
police officer
well of course they'll have to look at
those vetting procedures but i must say
it doesn't take
the smartest person in the world to ask
this simple question when a man who is a
police officer let alone anybody else
is caught flashing uh once and then
again twice
what in hell's name is he doing holding
a police badge and being able to operate
on the streets he should have been
suspended if not sacked immediately
pending an inquiry on the first occasion
i don't understand how that man was on
the street and thus able to murder sarah
everard uh you know we need to trust
these people and they have to be above
any kind of possibility of accusation
and the idea that a man can flash as a
police officer for goodness sake
and people think it's funny i think
that's that's the thing that's really
failed
you need to recognize that the police
police with consent and they are trusted
and therefore anybody who is his
colleague at the time who knew this was
going on
why in hell's name wasn't he immediately
reported suspended at least pending full
investigation had all his cards taken
off him or sacked i mean i think that's
simple as that and you don't need to
suddenly have a brilliant person come in
and review your
your your things that you do to assess
people what you have to do is say that's
it he's gone
in duncan smith thank you very much
well that's it for trevor phillips on
sunday uh on this
tragic and in many ways uh awful day
but we will be continuing to
delve into the issues in a moment after
the break with deputy political editor
sam coats in trevor phillips the take
[Music]
you